evening all okay I'm with my good friend
Chris we had a few games from towel
memorial today in in memory of Michael
tell one of the most exciting attacking
players ever in history of the game hi
Chris yeah trifon hey you're a fan of
make hotel as well aren't you yeah yeah
sure it's hard to be hard not to be
right because the game sounds so so
attractive to to play through and always
so surprising and I think that's the
common misconception that he always had
those incorrect attacks that could be
refuted and so on if you look at this
games I think it's very hard to to to
find really the holes in those kind of
combination and over the board it was
absolutely terrible to to play him I
guess with all those aggressive
aggressive poof's that he was able to
come up with yes it's very very nice to
have this really well-organized
tournament in memory of him yeah and we
had never had the privilege to to to
meet him it could have happened had
happened actually because I play dumb he
was living for a while at least
temporarily in the in the in the 80s
some Nehemiah my town here oh just a
couple of kilometers away because he
played for the for the Bundesliga club
day and cologne but he also took part in
some of those open tournaments met they
played really not really his kind of a
bit out of his League so to say just a
normal open tournament was it was a very
nice office because I know a couple of
people back then who actually met him
and he was really a super nice person
who also always always was analyzing was
with amateurs and playing blitz against
kits and whatever right so very
approachable and likeable person yeah
because some GM's are quite aloof on
either they really talk that much
with the bunnies haha yeah this really
didn't apply to too tall at all so on
yeah nice to have this tournament that
we had pretty um how would you call it
bloody first round with four victories
yeah out of 40 sides of games out of
five games so we've got two times more
victories in one round then in the whole
world championship match yes yeah and I
think we decided to to do a coverage of
the tournament enter what we do is I
think we will pick one game for each
round unless there are two absolutely
outstanding games we might do it
differently but I think just one game to
look at so it's a good choice so I think
actually someone just requested me on
icc as well to check out aronian against
the camera and that's funny enough is
the game before was the interesting the
most interesting game of the round today
so how did that play off so Aronian was
white and we've loaded into the ICC we
have approximate move relay times so
Aronian white kicked off with c4 so a
clash of styles is net between those two
the kymaro now the US Champion and
Aronian you know kind of solid
aggressive positional style yeah maybe
but now come were eyes so the start of
one trick pony it's not only playing
those well too technical games you can
also do very nice things so if you place
purely strategical so yes yes we saw
some yes some some examples in the u.s.
jump ship yeah so against the English
opening he elected be five yeah this is
some on the top level maybe the most
popular response to go to some sort of
reverses so yeah reverse Sicilian isn't
it okay it's also a bit remarkable the
Tyrolean plates before I usually plays d
4 in this match against chrome Nicki
actually experimented a bit with eform
but he's played c4 in the past also 93
varies a bit but let's say eighty
percent of the time he's playing d4 and
the other 20 years playing
thing of so here we got an English
opening for a change mmm and I think
it's a good term a good choice actually
to to get a fighting position because
those kind of positions that we will
also get in the game they're not the
kind of positions were white is getting
a huge advantage but tell me an opening
where white gets one Noah days what
white gets some a playable position with
lots of pieces on the board and I think
we should just go go through a couple of
moves see what I'm talking about so they
all got then lights out here now the
full night's english channel is called
the english full nights Bonnie chance
yeah and now g3 has main line and now
Nakamura likes to play the open Sicilian
with Carlos reverse basically black
could also play we should be 4 C 5 so
but we got an open Sicilian here just
colors reverse and it's a dragon yeah
important the difference to to the
normal dragon with them with them yeah
black actually going for the fianchetto
and the Sicilian is that black here is
basically forced to play night to be six
right because it can't play the standard
attack that you play as white against
the Dragons bit too slow he had a
problem is that why does just
threatening get d2 to d4 here if [ __ ]
be 64 here yeah yeah and this is already
critical from lack it's so difficult to
get a good position now or any position
at all what what should like do you
usually get oops something like this
here and it's it's difficult already
four blagghhhhh to to suggest something
actually got this in a tournament game
like two years ago mmm and that was
winning by move 12 or so well so free
the writing the opponent here thousand
two hundred twenty two thousand two
hundred on there is some are confused to
move forward i guess it's very very
difficult now what what should leg do
now me so like a not really play a slow
here also stuff like let's say I'm
upside if we revert back to the main
line sorry yeah exactly if black plays
black for something like this then I d5
just wins immediately this kind of
tricks are in the position all right
Knight takes c3 here is that yeah we've
got those yeah this is a typical might
take c6 you door combination and wide
emerges will pawn up at the end yeah why
just one upon right um no there's
nothing from like here unlike things
have taken to try this so but maybe you
can you can you can try to mean why
destroyed is better but Roy maybe it's
not winning porno chic night takes b7 is
winning the exchange with night d6 check
actually that is bad yeah that is that
is pretty oh sorry Knight takes oh it's
getting complicated the rock is saying
sorry go far off let's go back to them
oh yeah yeah yeah making Oh making it to
our video let don't do this oh ok so
black leg needs to play this ok Nakamura
spent about nothing time for this ok so
we've got castles and you should be 70 I
suppose mmm um and what what did Aronian
play no i only briefly later Lucy this
is actually a slight surprise already
because by far the men who was a 3 here
ah a 3 B form is so the usual kind of
procedure right of course often placed
III later but very often it is
considered to to go B form as quickly as
possible to have to be five idea so this
kind of idea to put pressure on the
sixth night and also on this pawn on e5
yeah so this is some a bit round but
certainly it's perfectly normal played
in thousands of games please but not so
common um yeah I guess castles um okay
and then we see Bishop e3 so there's an
intention may be to use the c5 square
later yeah
sexy I'm usually isn't that 94 to c5 but
you have to be careful about f5s from
black and so also a free and be four to
support something on c5 so that's like
using that Seto whites using that C file
i'll post usually in the senior yeah
it's a typical Sicilian strategy yeah
I'm contrary to UM lots of for
situations where white plays the open
Sicilian so with the reverse colors like
has very little chance here to to do
something against White's King like f4
and stuff f5 in this case you can you
can play this but you can rarely get a
king cytotec here you know what black
usually tries us too yeah centralizes
pieces and maybe after some preparation
play a move like I'm 94 here this is
what for black likes to do you know to
install pc and maybe provoke right you
to take it some oh yes to get pressure
down the earphones have a pool here
spicy collagen pressure e to this is
what you like to do but I think this
game progresses some a little bit
different let's see what happens to f5
Roxy one King h8 are you free pursuing
the b4 plan which not only supports
maybe a piece but also be five is going
to be dangerous for a five the Knights
dislodged so it's a dual-purpose plan i
think this sun by Bishop c5 first
dislodges the rook from that potentially
useful app file yeah i'm an important
and one one one little thing i'd like to
i'd like to point out just quickly if a
black would play a five year which is so
often a common on reaction to this a3
idea well it's a six and the sudden you
wiped off as a form here on right can
actually consider this kind of stuff and
then getting getting the lights on c4 be
five right this can can be very very am
annoying for black because you it's hard
to get rid of those two
nights and they will always put some
pressure on on b6 g 6 and so on yeah so
black needs to be cautious with this a
five min this year and nakamura also it
didn't play the player term so I'm this
Bishop of six year I think I mentioned
that in on chest gamescom just briefly
one of them because you know i did a
dual commentary of Daniel King and he in
in the Sicilian I Dolph's he's giving up
the protector of the light squares
sometimes the bishop to get access to
the dark squares and here it seems if
this picture can sometimes be given up
to get light square pressure it is yeah
what happened in Reverse yeah you just
destroy them likes care queenside
formation and you'd make use of all this
holds yeah under their positions of
course my black is completely okay after
this this this move but it's just
something you need to reckon that white
mad yeah my take down yeah okay so um it
went differently though so rook yeah as
though i don't know as though he for it
looks as though it's not ready on the
cards efore or is it now it may be is a
serious Freddy for and maybe that's why
why is interested to play efore himself
soon but not immediately but i think ii
for his later played in this game so
here ok what if black does try for it
looks is it premature your evening
default yeah yeah I think 11 if you look
at general considerations why does much
better develop so it looks so it looks
bit risky to open it up but of course
you need to calculate hmm I'm but I
think white can just take and doesn't
you just win the porn it's close to it
maybe you should take a brief look here
so taking like this would screw so what
what should like to know so it takes
like that I suppose rook Queens XD is
quite dangerous oh yeah you can you can
take and what what to SPECT play now
alright so he has to take with either
the bushel night that looks very
unpleasant yeah and then just my d2
I keep oh yeah you've got a locking key
on leaf rigs that Bishop anyway yeah
this thing is just it's just lost before
getting yeah it's getting yeah that's
hopeless yeah premature opening a foggy
okay so better to to get you are your
pieces develop you should be six yep
rookie one which gives the idea that
white might be too thin efore to exert
maybe pressure on e5 that might be an
idea he does play it now so it's
potentially going to have the option of
taking with pressure on e5 there with
maybe b5 as well to put pressure on that
e5 pawn yeah this kind of position is
what i meant with that that is let's see
for the english opening candy to very
tens and fighting positions because
let's let me have a look at just one
pair up on this exchange it's not
symmetrical and you get it takes a while
but you get a very complicated and
somewhat double-edged middle game and
this is exactly what to what we have
here maria difficult to play this
position yes by the way did you know
that GM i go smile off you know that gym
on youtube he's they are grating videos
and actually has gone through that that
recent world champion match finding some
key moments and some his sites where the
tension was released too early you know
the e takes d6 game which was a draw
after where those are anyway so
sometimes tension being released too
early is maybe as well as the
symmetrical porn structures why that
might match was quite dull because they
did release the tension a lot yeah yeah
as possible but here there's so much
tension there's only you know what's
been exchanged off not much there's a
huge amount of tension in this position
yeah and they're very young yeah they're
they're lot of possible changes in the
poor information also white could take
on f5 they could take on you for like a
play F form hey this looks shaky but
they're quite a couple of possibilities
and there are pieces on the board so hmm
there's still potential to to get some
real attack little pieces some playing
mm-hmm so um yeah what did like play now
I think if always a move which is really
interesting it weakens t3 also you need
to yes yes also take this into account
but you get some some ideas against the
five she already said you know and
you've got ideas maybe of taking on f5
here and sort of yeah clearly for form
for peace so very interesting positional
battle here yeah it's it seems a six was
designed to discourage be five when I
was looking at this earlier this
position this is one again I thought you
know this idea of the bezoar positional
sac giving up the bishop you can imagine
just imagine a fictional variation like
this you see why now night h4s ruled out
because that bishop but otherwise it
might be dangerous for that for the king
and these light squares but no it's not
working out is positionally and yeah but
wyd can can try to UM mmm play on the
light squares and display and I think it
does so in the game it's quite similar
what happens ah ok so a six and then so
Bishop H free looks a weird move doesn't
it Bishop h3 a little bit but sets
concrete problems for that doesn't it
about this f5 now yeah its own it's
certainly a bit strange looking but yeah
what what what what is black supposed to
do now maybe you're just threatening to
expose into some quite unpleasant
position here let's say um let's head
like what respect play now maybe put it
on the board I I only looked at this
game very briefly so I don't really know
what he played what did they play oh um
okay I can just choose edgy yeah member
say okay so you reacted to this idea
that I'm about to suggest let's say like
would play some some
nothing movie and hard to do one um
let's say some stuff like this it's
doing nothing I just to show maybe wide
can try to to put up something like this
and then install this night here hmm
maybe then stuff like this put pressure
on the farm yeah g6 also of course
immediately hopes this kind of idea I'm
not sure it would get some some nice
square here only form yes this might be
one of the ideas of bishop age three
yeah so he prevented this all together
with g6 to be able to recapture on f5
with a pawn okay so now we see Bishop
going back here so sort of done a job
there let's come back almost in sight
maybe it's going to be useful for night
g5s or Bishop g5 now yeah now know that
the here the dark squares are weakened
I'm a g6 leadership returns so Queen g7
guarding maybe h6 and putting more
support on e5 as well yeah night g5 is
used but the bishop has got a seemingly
useful retreat which it uses now are now
was that there wasn't a win of a porn
here because they'll be an attack on
this porch we just show that takes it
takes it's just attacking the night here
so that that's like this you know this
night is hanging and awesome and the f
for coming so white chester went back
you know now f4 very committal move f4
yeah you know blegh blegh just avoided
to draw here there should be 60 he could
have repeated oh so so yeah there should
be six is just repetition doesn't work
anything else apart from no idea i'm not
i'm not saying that white is better I
mean though it's a very complicated
position
it's hard to tell if I just got
something better Black has got that bind
on d4 now with everything pointing at d4
yeah it's difficult here to see how wide
should change the pawn structure because
I mean he doesn't want to take on f5
after G takes f it just opens the G file
and it doesn't help so you cannot move
the e porn D for as you pointed out is
very much controlled by All Blacks
pieces so how can wide make any programs
here it's difficult and in white really
isn't in a position to make any progress
and becca's of course better because I
mean he might be able to do something
when one writes isn't able to do
anything then the other player must be
the one to call the shots IAM difficult
to time I think knockout just young
played for William and hmm it's
interesting it's an interesting position
it's no need to to make a draw really so
f 4 and then Bishop takes basic so we
see this light square strategy sort of
like reverse Sicilian I Dolph idea of
giving up bishop to get more access to
the other squares of the bishes you just
get up also do just the only movie em
but but you're right the sir gives
chances to establish some play on the
light squares because this f4 move of
course also on this bishop yeah that
[ __ ] is great it's now doing so yeah
it's not quite sure often those kind of
pieces just pointed to thin air and do
nothing hmm but at least it's you can
imagine it doing something compared to
the position where the port sorry the
pawn was back on f5 yeah and um yeah I
don't know yep in this business right or
could be back don't down so yeah ok so
I'm sorry just yeah it's happens um I'm
not sure I like white yeah but this is
just my first initial impression it's
it's complicated and I'm not sure that
this was a good idea from Lex point if
you were to play in this way hmm well I
think
Bishop is useful for Bishop e6 is it for
example takes takes you could play here
well d 6 or bishop e6 maybe yeah at
least this move you know so at least I
mean if you another move that that I
would consider and now this line was
interesting um what I what I wanted to
show um says this here maybe also this
move I think this was a sour look also
hmm this is at least it's an idea like
takes now you've got this t6 also cause
roxy several is a bit of a menace as
well yeah yeah i think black on black
can i can actually handle this by
playing a form ah stuff like this so at
the end I think your Bishop be six is
the better move right okay you should be
we should be six is better i am what you
pointed out but it's hard to tolerate
this night yeah this is a problem it's
very strong piece and if like um gives
up his light squared Bishop then whites
michigan h3 might become really powerful
yeah it also can at any time return to
g2 and use the long diagonal so good go
on tough ride ahead here what did big
play rock da tour some g 554 very
directional a writing to win a piece so
that has to be parried wow Bishop d7
nice move it seems to be a very nice
move making is that night immediately
now so if Quinn sakes we have night
takes which would win the exchange as we
just put it on the board that will be
winning the exchange so what is and if
okay so what does he play here he played
rook e6 wow I think I think I should
play through this game more than one
sorry but I'll try and be more prepared
for these loser coming here's a shock to
me that you and you that yeah I mean
okay you need food second the exchange
here maybe answer
well what else could you play but it's
not quite sure how you should sec it
well this is not immediately obvious to
me because know it takes big sixes on
the cards as well okay I mean yeah yeah
it is but this looks so we're taking on
musics look strange to me a let's say
let's say you place rook da yeah you
know um and this move now this looks
weird you know in this vid okay and what
what does why do now maybe you can do
this you have you always had f5 and I
mean Bishop f5 or you could maybe even
take on c6 yeah this looks it looks a
bit strange yeah somehow Bishop f5 looks
more natural to me but might be wrong
hmm a very very difficult position so
let's let's check this again rookie six
okay yeah it's hard to to keep the two
yeah you need to sacrifice material
anyway and I think rookie 60 gets rid of
this this some annoying bishop at least
yeah it's trying to get a rebound on to
these light squares yeah yeah whites
whites king is a bit weekend of course
with the bishop missing so this will see
idea i guess to on to get some play on
the light squares and it is taken and
now knowing takes f6 wow a lot of
transactions are occurring now okay yeah
i think but aronia does now is a very
very high class kind of council
sacrifice counter positional sacrifice
now yeah it takes on c6 and bless queen
a 1 i'm amazing amazing isn't it it's
it's firm attic often in the sicilian
our dragon isn't it the exchange
sacrifice yeah it is to get the central
pawn and this is of course very very
visually pleasing
this F we nee one move yes Wow and yeah
very nice and also I'm just looking at I
just spotted a little another point here
and what does what to get plano oh yeah
if root d8 there's 95 not have seventh
in there if so look the eighth we've got
95 here only if nothing else no no maybe
no 95 disparate ace rude eh hopeless
isn't it you can just come clean your
fiber just we're cool positionally but
what I was just spotting is if leg takes
you this was the first concern here
because I mean the night is hanging on
f3 yeah and if you play something like
this it's a bit of very slight yeah my
own life yeah yeah so but you can you
can just simply captures also oh wow yes
yeah because you can check you can play
like this and I just winning you've got
an extra porn on everything's hanging
yeah c6 hangs and whatever so right is
just just winning here very nice mm so
but I cannot even take on g 30 it is it
doesn't bring him any benefits and so
why'd we will get to spawn back only
five yes and it's not like getting back
it's just winning it yeah he's got an
extra pawn here the central pawns are
just waiting all night to lost to expand
this Fisher sighing yeah that's a very
nice I think if we could just advance a
couple of moves and then we see the kind
of setup that arises which is very nice
choice to generate counts play a five
minutes that's not brilliant we've got
to connect to the past palms here um
okay she laughs and what is very nice a
whites-only small weakness yes as the
dat porn yeah and it's so nicely
protected by the night only five which
is at the moment not so easy to to get
away here black may come up with the
king like like this year but for the
moment this weakness is so nicely
protected and black has got this
see weakness on c6 also which is just
get advanced to see 5 but this is new
weakness on c5 we had to do that because
otherwise if white plays default is that
the idea d 4 was going to be strong
otherwise as well I just takes in six
will just take on c6 sorry yeah you take
this thing yes you can add coverage Arab
see a drop C 1 and that's it rook c8
will see one ya um so c5 here would be I
probably hear you just play what you
playing here text Jake c5f fine when the
endgame alright yeah i think or maybe
even Bentley I mean oh no no no just
just just play simple chest alright in
this pawns where you guys this thing has
just gone yeah like this here ah that's
what I mean time took it to capture the
porn yeah and like it doesn't have any
any counter play because this night only
five is such such a big piece if you
they look like let's say give the check
then I discovering g4 and everything so
black just has nothing here yeah very
very nice so I think he he needs to
advance the spawn young she did in the
game c5 takes ok but now this pool is
still vulnerable hands yeah you've got
two weak ones f4 and c5 and and yeah why
it's night is so nice only five to
protect you three ok this is providing a
receive full resource maybe of king of
free the seat for ya like once to get
caught yeah c4 would be strong but he
plays it anyway yeah I think it may be
you have no no no alternative and this
is just completely winning I guess if
you get these free now yeah so he still
got the two connected passed pawns ok he
doesn't mind giving up this because
these two should be stronger than that
one something that's what happens soon
oh no no he doesn't give up that pod me
jumping ahead so he's too porns up our
for not much compensation here now he's
giving up age to Padma now he's giving
up age to these two verses this one yeah
the tool two words is one of course the
huge advantage but also very important
this via White's King on f4 is just a
much better than later on a jade yeah
the king is actively helping those
points to to go forward so on this
should be lost really yeah there's a
very neat as fretting so this game isn't
there it's like a fantastic
demonstration of the power of the
reverse Sicilian dragon yeah maybe I
think but black I think was in a way I'm
not sure because really it's a I just
like you i just looked at this game on
you are we doing the the comments here
and i don't really feel like doing too
much criticism without ya looking at it
but i really don't think that black
wasn't any trouble or something it's
hard to imagine he may be he overdid it
a bit with this F for stuff yeah for
life g5 Bishop d7 this was a nice shot
you maybe this was just yeah a bit too
hasty and you need to prepared more just
speculation but it looked like maybe
black was expanding um yeah a bit too
quickly and was left with weaknesses and
white could nicely exploit here with
this counter sacrifice on c6 okay but we
are getting at you can gain now I which
which is played on a bit just to prove
these pawns a pretty dangerous check and
okay ah poor Morgan also writes King as
I mentioned this is actively helping
yeah and yeah this should be pretty
pretty easy when because like and can
cannot really do much because whites
Kings always what's in front of
the porn so horns here cover against any
ups any impossible checks here so this
age porn is really liability for for
black yeah the rook always needs to stay
there to cover this and it's just over
but what can you do so check all the
king is back there for a moment then he
goes all right so II 6 is now very
strong porn our rook g2 still cutting
the King off here yeah and detecting the
edge pawn and now yeah just edged gon
get just gets lost alright yeah because
if King HW spiky similar black resins
here if King a so he just play east of
its a knockout I Camaro resigned her
yeah it was the endgame was what's easy
at the end yeah I think it's somewhere
around moved 20 22 hmm well maybe black
gum liked it did something wrong here
maybe instead of a complete recap just
maybe go back quickly to this critical
position yeah um I think Iran 2022 or
something so you had that he had
reinforcements to the d4 square here
yeah I don't agree I just position
should be okay for black it's hard to I
mean it's also shown that it also shows
that aronian was repeating Lucia so are
you with the night retreat yeah so it
looks solid enough for blackness and
he's designing that d 4 which is like
White's Achilles Helen theory with this
structure yeah but so black just overdid
it one move allowing this rate powerful
positional sacrifice maybe f far worse
was too yeah what's a good premature
maybe I say sacrifices bishops are
usually worth more than nights so a tiny
bit but here but this 95 yeah it's
really dangerous this Bishop unlike at
all and this be sex is liable and then
so this this was beautiful though this
is this idea yes bishop
7 so willingly exchange with the idea of
sacrificing the exchange is very novel
it clears all the complications away if
you win the exchange then exactly yeah
this is a very very elegant way to to
finish this also i'm also i say moving
moving queens in the corners one of my
favorite moves so yeah it's elegant
isn't it queen i won I was very very
nice to just win this this big fan
report on only five yeah amazing and
then the pool my slideshow is logically
gonna win the game yeah because the
night only five is so strong very very
nicely done I think but Nakamura really
in I'm not sure maybe this fri one move
later f/4g five somewhere around there i
think things must have gone terribly
wrong before like shouldn't be really in
huge problems or any problems at all
question I didn't read any player
statements or press conference or
whatever I think they they do those
press conferences after the game on
similar to to to the World Championship
match and this is often interesting i
think to get a pretty close inside from
the from the front of the players right
after the game how they assess the
position so what we don't have this
information yet but i don't really think
that that should have been worse lego
move 20 and so on 19 let's say i have
four left my doubts ok it was looking at
the game I think um I bet goats dinner
before I get on murders so I make sure
we wrap it up there thanks Chris yeah
yeah let's let's check in the coming day
so for more interesting game so maybe we
will cover 11 daily not sure how we
manage and we'll check if there are
interesting games to show then we'll
bring it up on our Channel turn ok
everyone enjoyed it on YouTube comments
or questions on Bo four channels
kingscrusher interests explain first
very much